so we have this story it's from western
standard now i have to say i'm not
familiar with what western standard is
i've never read them before
and uh part of me wants to say well i
don't know if i can trust this news
outlet i gotta be honest when i read the
mainstream media i often know that i
can't trust them so i'll just say this
take it with a grain of salt for what it
is this is what they're reporting
they're reporting that alberta towing
companies are rejecting requests to
supply trucks to the rcmp quote a lot of
these smaller companies don't want to
ruin their reputation in the communities
they serve so they don't want to get
involved i mean
that sounds
that sounds
i mean completely
correct and reasonable i mean imagine
you have a small business you're a tow
truck driver you know everyone loves the
truckers and the police are like go toe
you're gonna be like no
and if you if you read down in the story
it does say that they actually were
calling the tow truck companies directly
to get quotes from them and that they do
have a few listed you know they said
they talked to some people out of the
calgary area and they've got they've got
names and specifics involved in this so
you know it seems like pretty good
reporting um
but it's the same idea that look these
guys are in the calgary area these tow
truck companies and they're saying look
we work with the trucking industry on a
regular basis right you're asking us
essentially to go after our own
customers and our friends and our
partners and our b2b contracts that
we've got and that we would obviously
relationships that we don't want art to
have you know to injure and so
we're not going to take this work and we
just don't want to get involved and you
know the mounties are saying come and
get them so then the mounties are going
to turn around and say well wait a
minute you know what do we do like how
do we get rid of all the trucks even if
they go in certainly they can arrest all
the truckers but that wouldn't move
when you're just not here just to move
the trucks right you need the the
trucker is right they've got you know
the keys and i don't even know if the
mounties you know do they have cdls can
they drive those drugs do they have the
infra that's actually one of the
beautiful things about the trucker
protest right because you know the
logistics are this is what they always
say is that
uh uh amateurs talk strategy
professionals talk logistics what think
about it right actually think through
this what if you wanted to shut down
these protests logistically how would
you do it
well that's the beauty of these protests
right you can't you actually can't i
mean i was mentioning this the other day
if the protest is literally everyone
says let's go drive downtown no one's
broken any laws
so sure you've got these big rigs that
are pulling into the city and they're
honking their horns but if the cop walks
up to one of these rigs saying ottawa
who's honking the horn or who's on the
highway and they say hey everyone's got
to get out of here you got to move back
buddy i'm not here with the convoy i'm
just driving my truck what are you going
to do about it right yeah
your intent is within your brain
illegally parked your truck
yeah i mean if you're if you if if they
all go to downtown ottawa and they're
all bl and the city's gridlocked the
cops can walk up to and say move your
car like i want to
be like no more protesting i'm not
protesting i'm just driving my car we're
stuck also the fact that
truckers have this kind of power when
they protested and power that we never
considered i mean so we all understand
that they deliver the food to us they're
incredibly important but everything
you're mentioning about the fact that
you couldn't tell them tim what you're
saying about the fact that the police
could never really enforce a suppression
of their protest because you can't
determine intention in that way it just
goes to show that for all the leverage
that they've had the fact that this is
the first time that they're actually
speaking out and having a protest of
this sort really speaks a to their
collective character and b the fact that
they're probably right about this this
isn't a group of people that's
constantly fretting and trying to get
their way this is a serious issue and
they're saying can we please be taken
seriously as valued members of society
and be allowed to determine what is put
into our own bodies i'll tell you this
this is
the
so
it's a brilliant protest the trigger
convoy they're going about very very
smart uh
tactfully
there's a lot truckers could do to
completely
shut down a country yes and they're not
doing it because that would probably
piss off too many regular people
imagine if on all of the two lane
highways across the united states two
truckers just went 20 miles under the
speed limit and drove side by side yep
grit just jamming up every interstate
across the country and it would only
take a couple hundred trucks to do it
now imagine if you had 50 000 truckers
across the us who all decided just the
two of us right now in this spot are
going to are going to cause a major
traffic jam tim you're going to accuse
you of inciting violence now in the
media for saying that some truckers
gonna do this i'm kidding no they're not
trucker truckers do this in protest i'm
saying if they wanted to go to a larger
scale they could and they're choosing
not to they're just in a big convoy
showing everybody that they they support
a cause they oppose the mandates yeah
imagine if they actually tried to
disrupt trade imagine how insane first
of all
imagine if they just said i'm not
driving today so nobody brings food if
they did a general strike imagine if
they were like i'll drive but we're
gonna drive real slow there's so much
they could do they're choosing not to do
well and think about too and trudeau
even has i found his tweet the other day
you know he had hashtag thank a trucker
the other day because so think about it
all of the blue city
leftists that have been supporting
lockdown policies for all of this time
because they've got their cinecures
they're making their money right they're
all still getting paid for sitting at
home doing nothing they're doing
ubereats they're getting you know
they're getting their netflix the reason
that they have supplies their entire
lifestyle was upheld that entire time
because simply because to your point
truckers never went off the job truckers
never stopped working truckers are
literally essential workers right you
know there's this whole you know i i
don't even know who it was that came in
and said oh the news media is a central
reality i don't think the news media is
essential no you're not even right no
truckers yes absolutely an essential job
well hold on uh no and it's those so
those things down my point journalists
it's those same exact people who are
attacking the very people
that allowed you to be able to live
through those lockdowns when you were
living lives of luxury for an entire
year
i got to push back journalists are
essential workers but we don't have any
is the problem we have like a small
handful in this country yeah so when you
know cnn is like we're essential workers
i'm like shut your mouth like not you
know when you have the small handful of
actual reporters people like matt tybee
for instance and what rebel news is
doing there on the ground that's
essential reporting but cnn's panels
about donald trump during covet please
you know these truckers in canada
actually remind me remember a lot long
ago we had the sauce with the pilots
caught in sick yeah cancer results
that's right it's theirs in a peaceful
way to also protest but this is
interesting i actually talked to a pilot
to understand because the media said
there's no sick out it's fake news so i
i talked upon the phone and he said
there is no sick out there is no protest
it's worse than that what had happened
was
the mandates had stressed the workforce
to the point where they were just
individually saying i'm gonna call in
sick today wow so it wasn't like anyone
organized anything you know what i was
being told by this guy was like listen
the idea that there's an organized
protest means there's a lot of people
who are just following the leader but
this is actually grassroots when they
announce the vaccine mandates a lot of
employees just said okay i'm going to
use up what sick time i have left and
i'm done so all of these people calling
and saying disrupting everything well
the media was correct it wasn't a mass
protest
it was worse the system was collapsing
yeah it could be individual just to
start to resist and stress out it's like
i just don't feel like going to work
anymore you know and that's the beauty
of it i said you know that's good we
have so many people like that in this
country once they had enough of the kobe
two years shut down rise of tyranny and
the people it's like this is not the
american we know about and now what's
going on also in school shut down
schools parents cannot go to work
learning stuff that they don't approve
online and tell parents you could be
potentially domestic terrorists people
people are made up yeah one thing that's
actually going i think to be an
unintended consequence of this is that
truckers all of a sudden just found out
how important they are that's what i'm
saying
the next level so you're gonna see by
the way a lot of the you know for if
there's collective bargaining that goes
on they're gonna be getting paid and
you're gonna see i do think you're gonna
see a lot of people now looking out at
this and saying you know what
that doesn't actually look like a bad
life you know
right you don't need you you you don't
need to go to college you don't need to
get massively in debt you go get your
cdl which you can study for it you can
get it you learn the basic mechanics of
being able to operate a big rig you go
out there and it basically is if you are
willing to spend that much time on the
road but hey you get to listen to
long-form podcasts like tim cast irl
while you're driving you're driving and
others while you're driving the truck
and
you know you you get to see tons of
parts of the country and you get to make
bank we actually have a friend
who
immigrated here on the green card
lottery from eastern europe um came to
the u.s literally i picked him up at
dulles airport him and his wife with
they had two suitcases with them but he
was a commercial truck driver back home
learned enough english to be able to
pass the test within five years he he
owns two of his own trucks now owns a
home he's been driving his wife's
english is better than his so she's a
dispatcher and he's been to like all 50
states already yeah well with except
well 49 not hawaii yet so
one thing i was
sort of touching on and wanted to get
into a little bit here is the fact that
for as unbelievably powerful and
important truckers are as a collective
group the fact that we have not heard as
much from them as a force as you tend to
hear from other unions and worker
organizations and groups of people in
this country and i don't know that it's
so much the case that truckers just
realized how important they are now i
think they've known but this is one of
the professions where people still
genuinely care about the contribution
they're making to society rather than
just what they're taking home in terms
of money and also i have to say this
another reason why i do genuinely
believe that they care about what
they're doing they care about what
they're providing and they tend to be
more down-to-earth people is because
this is one of the few professions where
you can support a family that does not
require a college education right and
that means these people are not going
off to these institutions to be
brainwashed with all these ridiculous
ideas and coming out as communists and
look at how the establishment left
smears and insults people who don't have
college degrees yeah this this this
condescension this elitism
it's uh smarmy it's gross
and it shows that it's stained for
working-class people exactly there's a
there's a comic that's uh funny it's
from stone toss and i love how the left
really really despises stone toss i
don't know much about them other than
there's comics on the internet and one's
good and it's a leftist being like you
know the workers of the world you know
workers of the world unite and then it's
a right-wing guy and he's going across
and he's like all right i'm in and then
the leftist is like
no nothing
it's like it's like we support the work
this this is by the way where you get
um marxist leninism comes out of marxism
and then eventually maoism came out of
that because
um the problem that lenin realized in
trotsky early on was that the workers
just weren't revolting against the
government the way that that marx had
intended for them to do with historic
progression and so they really they you
know the realization that lenin had was
that marx missed something that you need
this revolutionary vanguard that can
lead them through and i'm actually
reading about halfway done um
uh pyota rangel's always with honor now
he was the leader of the white army in
the russian civil war so you know my
background's more in china chinese civil
war cultural revolution but i said you
know what you know russia is actually
where it happened first and so mystery
growth publishing is doing their book
you know they're bringing it's actually
his autobiography his memoirs that have
come forward and it's amazing number one
because he's a great writer it's just
he's really good at writing um you know
giving a narrative but also he explained
that the bolsheviks of their time it was
exactly the same as what we're living
through now so exactly the same yeah i
want to add something people might not
know
um workers rule sounds great the
proletarian rule but if you grew up in
china like i did when you actually a
worker's family you have least amount of
food rationing coupons you live in a
primitive conditions and you always work
look dangan i have
literally working parents i
grew up in that neighborhood everybody
looked down on me because i i'm a
daughter of illiterate workers parents
or starving and then later you know once
companies take over the workers cannot
unionize there's no independent unions
in china because you have to have a
communist party committee
to supervise your workers organizations
so you lose your actual workers rights
so people cannot buy into that can
yeah you go but i want to ask lily
question there's a viral video on reddit
right now because on reddit a whole
bunch of leftist extremists forums are
becoming increasingly popular like late
stage capitalism anti-work work reform
they're overtly communist but there's a
video going viral of a guy explaining
how capitalism is modern slavery
and it's one of the
most
i don't know if this guy he's got he's
got a podcast where he talks about
capitalism being evil i don't know if
he's just an evil guy who's lying to
seize power you know he wants to
convince people to support a cult
ideology or if he's just really dumb
but he said
he's like in capitalism
you will never be paid what you're worth
that's a myth you have to be paid less
than you produce for the employer who is
your feudal lord who takes the excess of
your labor and steals it and i'm just
like and you can choose to quit and then
you can choose to start your own
business and then you can become a lord
whereas in feudalism you couldn't
whereas in these other countries with
slavery you couldn't just leave that
position but this is right this is the
essential link between communism and
capitalism that nobody likes to discuss
because both are two sides of the same
coin of materialism and i know where you
know that our absolutely is that if you
are basing your entire system around
material goods and material wealth then
you're going to find one system or
another that supports it or supports the
reallocation of it in in terms of
socialism whereas if you look at
capitalism as a tool right so okay we
will we like free enterprise right we
want free enterprise but that doesn't
mean that the economy the needs of the
economy the needs of the gdp should come
at the you know should be given priority
over the needs of families or over the
needs of people that actually live in
these communities that's why our country
has been hollowed out the way it's been
because of this merger between us and
the ccp that's been going on for 30
years that's why the jobs have been
shipped overseas and there was someone
on a podcast recently who was saying
that it's actually a good thing that
american jobs were all shipped over to
china and all of the wealth was shipped
over to china and that's ridiculous
because what that did was it empowered
the ccp it funded the growth of the
chinese military through american fdi
that's where this is going
we have underwritten it and lily you and
i were talking earlier about how the
city of shanghai that you know the area
across the river pudong has gone in 30
years from being
you know farmland into one of the most
built up financial capitals of the world
well guess what to the american people
you paid for that you all paid for that
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you